but also nice to have you here
Thanks so it's complexity semester well
it's fine grain complexity and algorithm
design is a fine grain okay yeah what is
fine grain so fine grain means making
more precise distinctions so in
complexity you know there's the famous P
versus NP problem and it's about how
many steps does a computer or algorithm
have to go through to search for the
solution or find the best solution when
there could be a huge exponential number
of solutions and so the P versus NP is a
kind of coarse-grained attempt I had
addressing this question because it's
saying is there a really fast algorithm
for this problem well we're looking very
important in real time so like so yeah
so if you think of it in terms of the
input size it's not so fast saying P
means very fast you know almost like
without even thinking about all the
space of possible solutions exhaustive
search on the other hand is very slow
considering every single possible
solution and sort of the more fine-grain
version of this question is how much can
we be how much can we improve over
exhaustive search even not all the way
to be not all the way to P necessarily
probably not if P is different from NP
but maybe we can like cut the dimension
of the search space in half still
exhaustively search through it but
search through a space that's group of n
over 2 2 to the N over something like 2
or 2 or even like point 9 and write only
in one direction you could show that you
need to to the point at point 9 and I'll
time then it would certainly prove it's
a much stronger than just that P not
equal NP and actually well it would
prove the version of P in article 20
that we have been all been dreaming of
because there are there are nightmarish
versions of that yeah where it's kind of
a close call you know but this would say
it's not even close mmm-hmm and as far
as like current technology goes for many
you know current knowledge of algorithms
go for many problems it's not even close
so so that is the as you said the P
versus NP question which is the
overarching question about via and out
of this you carve throughout the fine
grain question I mean you think that as
a right way to carve the problem well so
it's right in that just away my standard
for the right way to carve the problem
is is sort of like the the cut the cake
and then let you see its cues which half
you want okay so it should be good to
get either half mm-hmm and the way it's
good this is a good way of cutting the
cake is that if for some reason we get a
two to the point nine an algorithm for
some of these problems and this is a
very counterintuitive consequence will
actually get a lower bound an
impossibility result for other problems
by a very indirect method not at all
obvious but an almost binary in fact
again we get much stronger lower bounds
or do we ever know for from from an
algorithm for monogamy okay and on the
other side of the cake if we if it's
really hard if you can't have a two to
the point nine algorithm 0.9 an
algorithm for the problem then not only
and again this is like not a direct
argument not only do you show that
certain np-complete problems are really
high
but there's a way of translating it down
to separate problems with in polynomial
time and I think the back-back person
and Indyk result is probably the most
spectacular that if this is true then in
fact the the Edit distance problem one
of the very basic problems in
computational biology can't be sped up
over what we know and what we know is an
N squared algorithm which by P versus NP
standards is a fast algorithm but by
computational biologists on toads if
it's horrible because the N is the size
of the genome and multiplying that by
itself becomes prohibitive exactly yeah
so people in practice don't use exact
algorithm for at a distance they use
heuristics because even N squared time
is just not fast enough